well nothing worthwhile but let's keep
going
hey so with our luck what are the odds
this volcano is going to erupt on us
zero it's extinct that's me that's the
first thing I looked at when we said we
were heading for a volcano that we're to
rent the cheapest woman wait Sully you
telling me that you actually did some
research can't let you be the
know-it-all every time that bridge there
is what you would call Brittany
this looks promising
come on come on baby let's go go go go
go
baby
okay kid just don't drop us just keep it
slow keep it in the center Jeff there's
a lot of maxi to go good everything's
good
Antoinette would
I got my okay I know we're fast you need
traction here okay go get the hang of
this there we go
No Jesus oh my spine
look tire tracks someone came up this
way
hey Victor what were you arguing with
the rental guy oh yeah brother insisted
on getting a 4x4 with a winch so you
sprung for the winch but you couldn't
spring for the suspension I got it
hey it's important going offroad it
might rain like muddy
take this slow yeah
so making you think in Avery too and
some other bigshot pirates pooled their
treasure and came out here because why
exactly who knows
maybe for protection British authorities
were closing in on him
sure maybe he helped them disappear any
the guy clearly had a knack for hiding
things
let's go check out that top I'll come
with it's a pretty good shape of
something several hundred years old
yeah definitely ruins from Avery's era
Sam look that's Christopher Condon
schedule he's captain of the fiery
dragon operated out of Madagascar around
Avery's time so maybe Avery recruits
pirate captains to what be as lookouts
no make me sense
no doesn't well maybe each captain was
responsible for a tower along with
providing the men far whatever the case
it certainly isn't our final stop on our
tour
huh bark stripped away something was
wrapped around this tree
did you know our car came with a winch
what you gonna do it not sure yet
they're how to do it look like from
steeper than it looks
all right ready give it a shot
here we go teddy
daddy
Sulli which totally worried we clear the
hill it hasn't exactly paid for itself
well yeah small victory yeah well I'll
celebrate the big ones
feast your eyes gentlemen Wow
spectacular just imagine you've come
here a well-to-do pirate far away from
your oppressive government Oh
poor oppressed pirates all they wanted
to do is to murder and pillage and peace
no no they wanted to live as free
tonight well if you got to pick a place
to run away from society it's not worse
than here
it's taken forever to get to this
volcano patience Victor paste it do you
know how those pirates got here they had
to start in England sailed to Brazil
then cut back across the Atlantic to
South Africa and they figured all that
out with paper charts and by looking at
the Stars
hey you're describing Salem to a former
squid the point is we got it pretty easy
yeah still taking a long time on one
second I just wait with Sam